dear fellow scholars I'd like to draw
your attention to the witness which is a
computer game that helps you improve
your scientific thinking and reasoning
skills it is a first-person game and if
you like solving puzzles well it has
them in abundance before we start I'd
like to note for transparency that if
you're worried about spoilers everything
shown in this video is taken from the
first 5 to 10 minutes of the game also
this is not a sponsored video I'm not
paid for any of this and just absolutely
spellbound by this game after completing
it I felt that I learned so much and
felt so much smarter which is something
that I did not feel playing through any
other game i remember that i felt sorry
after beating every single puzzle as
there was less and less left from the
game i just absolutely love how this
game approaches the concept of teaching
it never says a word it guides you by
creating appropriate puzzles for you to
overcome it teaches without teaching
first we're shown that we have to reach
the exit from a starting point however
there is many different ways of doing
that so to keep it challenging we have
to put constraints on the problem it
seems that these white and black blocks
have to be in separate regions we now
have seemingly the same puzzle but we
realized that by changing something as
simple as the position of the exit our
previous plans fall apart and we often
have to think outside of the box to
overcome these new challenges I see an
empty block over there who knows how it
will react if I lock it together with a
white block there's an opportunity to
try it for educational purposes I'll
ignore it for now another slightly
changed puzzle another time when we need
a complete redesign this series of
puzzles beautifully displays how the
slightest change to a problem can
require us to completely rethink our
approach in this last puzzle we need to
use these empty blocks to create one big
region with all
the white markers we had the opportunity
to learn about the empty blocks before
but even if we missed it the game makes
sure we understand this concept by the
end of this challenge beautiful design
these were of course tutorial level
educational puzzles from the very start
of the game later the search space will
be too large to just guess randomly so
we have to systematically put
constraints on the problem and eliminate
a large number of solutions if we do
this more and more we inevitably end up
with the right solution this is exactly
the kind of thinking that is required
for scientific breakthroughs some of the
teachings really remind me of the book
by the name the art of learning by Josh
Waitzkin he discussed that improvement
in almost any field comes by challenging
and overcoming dogma dogma means a set
of principles that are so deeply
entrenched in our minds that we take
them for granted and are unable to
challenge them for example in karate
fighting on a ground
is deemed to be not honorable therefore
they don't practice it a wrestler would
exploit this weakness and use it to his
advantage and smash them into the ground
the author of the book defeated his
opponents in chess and martial arts by
not only finding out their dogma but
inserting dogma into their heads and
using it against them one great example
of that in martial arts is when you are
facing a weaker opponent who pushes you
if you didn't want to you could remain
unwavering but what is even better is
pretending to move when he pushes you
after a few times your opponent will be
undoubtedly sure that when he pushes you
you will move and in the decisive moment
when he pushes you will remain still and
imbalance and counter-attack your
opponent will be swiftly defeated and
won't have any idea what really happened
this book is such a great read check it
out the witness often tries to do the
same it inserts Dogma in your head
without you noticing it and will ask you
to break through it to overcome new
challenges and it does it in the most
beautiful way I have seen thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time